pass or smash fake it till you make it
mentality there's a lot of value in it
but I think it's misunderstood when
you're faking it till you make it
there's a level of manipulation going on
I mean there's a lot of lying that comes
along with it have conviction that
you're gonna make it and act as if
that's very different than fake it till
you make it today there are more
founder-led personal Brands than ever
how can
um especially for this in this case
women protect themselves and their
personal brand
oh there's so much to this first of all
thank you for having me on the show of
course and congrats on everything
um
I I think you protect yourself by having
a strong mental Foundation
right like vulnerability
um of protection like growing winning
having things happen the way you want
starts at home and at home I don't mean
in your four walls I mean in your brain
you have a sense of who you are are you
strong
what's your level of confidence versus
your insecurity are you a person that
likes to judge as escapism from your own
pain because you judge your own self so
you know I think before we get into any
level of tactics it starts upstairs and
you know I feel like
I feel like women entrepreneurs are
extremely strong at speaking about
vulnerability and speaking to topics
that are meaningful I think men try to
posture they they struggle with that
level but I think a lot of female
entrepreneurs have a head start I speak
to so many female entrepreneurs who will
spend a lot of time and energy
explaining to me why men entrepreneurs
have it easier but it's really ironic
because I believe that emotional
strength and emotional work is really
the game of how this all works in the
end I think the level of conversation on
the female entrepreneur sector tends to
skew better and higher in the frequency
of the conversations are deeper and more
thoughtful and I actually think that you
know sometimes that for some people they
think that they're wasting too much time
or energy on that but I think that's the
actual work and so what I would say is a
continuation of path of like really
feeling confident which speaks to
cutting out the cavities of insecurity
people have to work on tuning out those
voices while equally respecting that
they may have value there's a really
fine balance of like taking in advice
but not making it
like gospel right like for example I do
this with negative comments
negative comments I don't dismiss as
trolls or haters I try to take in is
there any truth to the observation and
try to take the good from it I can
separate the Venom that it's delivered
with often and try to see if there's any
truth same thing I do with positive like
when people put a goat Emoji do I think
I'm the greatest of all time I don't I
aspire to
but I don't like take it in and I try to
like preserve my humility the same way
that I try to preserve my sanity and
confidence and joy and lack of anxiety
and so you know I think um you have to
take in what those voices are saying but
you can't fully internalize them you
have to decide if you agree or disagree
but if you agree you act on them and if
you don't agree you articulate to why
you don't but you don't do it like in an
Abrupt way hey I built this before you
were here I don't need your [__] I just
needed your like you got people have to
find ways to communicate with class
we've gotten into this place in society
where we communicate so poorly because
politicians have showed us the way
um and now it's trickled into day-to-day
you know I tell people to really find a
way to communicate with class
I love that thank you
I I always say just live an Integris
life so yeah it's like no matter what
you do yeah that's right be as nice as
you can but why not like explain to me
why not because they hurt my feelings
well guess what if they hurt your
feelings they're probably hurting maybe
you can deploy some Compassion or
empathy like the wine you're drinking
yeah I'm just gonna say why not why not
you know why not deploy some empathy
um you know and so you know I I think
that people need to really get within
their head and figure this stuff out
keep going how important is brand versus
marketing and sales because you really
put an emphasis on brand and you share a
lot too that the larger companies yeah
aren't really realizing the importance
of brand
well they actually do and actually the
biggest companies in the world
understand the value brand probably more
than influencers and creators they're
just they don't understand where brand
is being built they think commercials
and billboards and print ads and banner
ads on websites and pre-roll intrusion
ads on digital and dorky posts on social
is building brand and my point is
perfect social or best social or
strategic social is where brand is being
built and I think to your point a lot of
people in this community of creators and
influencers they're so transactional
like everything is to selfish needs how
many followers can I get how many likes
am I getting how much money can I get
from this brand deal and so it's it's
very sales oriented the reality is both
matter you know like if you've built
unlimited brand but you don't know how
to close that Equity into a sale well
you're going to go out of business but
if you're just a salesperson and you're
not building brand they're going to move
on to the next Creator to the next
person to the next brand and so
um you know they both matter a lot but I
think I think that sales is just people
that aren't great at brand and what I
mean by that is
you know when I look at the best
personalities businesses you know Ryan
Reynolds doesn't sell
he's brand and you just like I I just
wanted mint mobile I'm like I've been on
Verizon 100 years I'm like Oh my like
the when when Kevin Hart makes a funny
video like and he's got his tequila in
it like I just want to support him he's
not he's not sending me an email saying
buy my buy a case of my tequila
you know and so I think when you build
brand it's special you recently shared
um an analogy or uh I think it was
either in your book or one of your
podcast episodes but it was analogy of
building a bigger building versus
tearing other buildings down can you
share that just for our listeners
did you like this one yes I'm obsessed
with this one this has been one that
I've been with since I was a teenager
it's a very old adage
which is
there's two ways to build the biggest
building in town one build the biggest
building in town you were just that
talented you were just that capable
you've put in that work two tear down
everybody else's building and then thus
your building seems bigger even though
it might not be that big
I believe that we have now gone into the
phase in our society of tearing
everyone's building down the amount of
finger pointing the amount of judgment
and so people have no capacity for
respecting other people's opinions or
thoughts
um or success I'm thrilled when other
entrepreneurs are doing their thing I
just brought up two of them in this
analogy two actors who I think are real
when I think about the rock or
um or you know or Ryan Reynolds or Kevin
Hart or Reese Witherspoon or Jessica
Alba these are people who've
transitioned from Fame to operating
entrepreneurs building humongous things
you know to me I have great joy in
watching other people win doing this
podcast is a way for me to accelerate
your winning
thank you right and so what do you think
all those people have in common that you
see in them well those people I just
mentioned just happen to be
entrepreneurial and ridiculously
hardworking like the demonization of
hard work
is is a very dangerous fine line mental
health issues
that you get from overworking or caring
only about money is a tremendous topic
yeah and it's exactly right
but demonizing work ethic as not one of
the required things to build something
meaningful is laughable and delusional
and then you probably know this there's
an enormous amount of your listeners
right now who just love the work like
when you love your work it's play so
finding the balance but I think the
thing that I see in people that tear
down buildings is they're unhappy with
themselves thus they're just trying to
make everybody else misery loves company
or they just don't know they know that
they don't have the talent to just build
on their own Merit and they know that
they can bully or tear down or out
politicize people like when I say I'll
politicized I don't mean politics I mean
in business World some for example some
people will say well if you work with
that other person you're not going to
work with me and they know that you're
giving them more business and that's
because they're worried about this
upstart gal in town doing a thing like
you know and so like I think that's
horrible I don't want to lose to my
competitors
but I respect my competitors in my
businesses if they're able to accomplish
in our game and I admire it and I cheer
for it and I also don't think that
anyone is taking away from me I don't
think anyone's success is taking
happiness out of my pocket money out of
my pocket growth out of my pocket the
world is abundant there's enough for
everyone at scale and um I just think
that way too many people are insecure
out there and it's manifesting in in
poor Behavior which is really
unfortunate because they might be
tricking a lot of people but they're not
tricking the two percent
that are most emotionally intelligent on
Earth so when I see people that
seemingly look like they're doing well
and they're winning
um I feel bad for them yeah me too
and so uh that's part of the live
beautifully podcast how to live more
beautifully okay I know we don't have
that much more time left but I would
love for you to share the 12 and a half
ingredients to success so that way
someone can go read your book because I
really think that these words obviously
you had a lot of intent behind them if
you can remember them
like everybody can go to Amazon and see
those words on the cover and we can talk
about accountability or patience or
curiosity which I think is a weird one
and you're right I had a lot of intent
or me being vulnerable and talking about
Candor being very important but me
struggling with it I actually want to go
a different way because I think this
will bring even more value to your
audience
when you see those words which one hit
you as like [__] you know like my
intention with the book it's 13 traits I
called it 12 and a half because I talk
about in the book hey Candor has been my
kryptonite I don't like telling people I
love which are my employees that they're
bad or that I'm gonna fire them it's the
worst feeling on Earth and it's really
[__] up a lot of things in my life
that's just the truth because if you
can't be candorous you really open up
yourself to being full of [__] and
people don't like full of [__] right and
so I'm just curious when you saw those
words what kind of hit you
I've always related to you when it has
to do with having Candor and I didn't
even know what that word really was and
now I've explored how that has been
difficult for me as an entrepreneur I'm
a people pleaser and so even if it's
employees I just want everyone to be
happy and to like me and to love their
job but giving feedback has always been
even when I would do reviews I'd
actually have people review themselves
I'm like on a scale of one to ten how
punctual are you
um but I also think you're doing a
disservice like you say like as a leader
we owe it to them to give them feedback
that's really kind it's also not going
to work like what's going to happen is
anybody who's functionally capable
you're eventually going to fire them and
you went from being nice I mean I used
to think I was being nice I was like
this person stinks at Wine Library this
person stinks at vaynermedia I'm letting
them stay here for another year in this
beautiful atmosphere and I'm nice and
like I'm doing a Mitzvah I'm like the
greatest guy ever and then you have to
fire them and they're like you're a
piece of [__] you made me think I was
great the whole time nobody ever gave me
any negative feedback what the [__] this
came out of nowhere and I was like man
this is really not working like like I'm
over here thinking I'm being Santa Claus
and these people are like when I review
in my lifetime
the dozens and dozens of people versus
the thousands of thousands of people who
adore me the dozens and dozens of people
who have a bad taste in their mouth that
working at Wine Library vaynermedia or
anything of that nature I'm like uh
every one of them was everyone all of
them all of them
were the same story they weren't up to
my standards subjectively they were just
my subjective standards I was unable to
communicate to them their exit in the
company was super sloppy because I
actually had a lot and the more I love
them the sloppier it was yeah yeah
because they care about them so once I
rebranded it to myself as kind candor
you know I had a breakfast yesterday and
I gave Canada and it's uncomfortable
still to me I went from a one out of ten
to a four out of ten maybe a five out of
ten I've seen huge dividends but still
it's like pulling teeth for me to be
like you're late or you're not extra
hard work it's just because you care all
right we only have a couple minutes left
I want to do this so we're doing pass or
smash which I know that you want to give
context on all of them yep Hazard smash
chat GPT smash
focus groups of 100 people smash
Twitter
smash lemonade
double smash it's how I learned business
oh uh
yeah well I'm sorry I haven't dug super
oh lemonade you can start selling
lemonade early
um I haven't I haven't gone deep on it
I'm obviously very aware but I am I that
one I just have to say neutral because I
haven't tasted it yet Fair
uh using trends
smash
fake it till you make it mentality
let me double click on that
um
there's a lot of value in it
but I think it's misunderstood when
you're faking it till you make it
there's a level of manipulation going on
let me wear the suit let me make up I
mean there's a lot of lying yeah that
comes along with it so I think fake it
to you make it would be a little bit
different have conviction that you're
gonna make it and act as if I like that
very different than fake it till you
make it which comes with a lot of
baggage of like sleazy behavior that
actually can become very
um dangerous because you can't become
used to it and then when you make it
some of those things that got you there
with the faking it actually become your
scarlet letter and your vulnerability of
losing it so fake it to you make it may
lead to you losing it
have conviction that you're going to
make it and acts that act as if becomes
a healthier version of it I like that
standing desks
I'm a little bit neutral on that
um meaning uh I'm actually gonna say
smash because my back is killing me
right now and I think culprit is sitting
like an idiot all through all of covid
so let me take that back I'm gonna go
with smash
snooze button
smash I [__] use it I know a lot of
people like garyvee and I [__] need
that I need I use it I used it today for
10 minutes box twine
black swine is horrible like I know
people trying to say like like it's
getting better it is but let me give a
huge thing for everybody on here the
level of wine that you can buy between
12 and 20 a bottle is staggeringly high
and the stuff you're getting in a box
wine though much cheaper because
obviously that goes down to two three
four bucks a bottle
like [__] wine is such an epic thing
like if you just go to 12 bucks the
whole world opens up
um and I think people should make that
investment if they're drinking wine
drink water if you want to drink four
dollar wine
uh losing
uh smash I think falling in love with
micro losing is what makes you the
ultimate winner I think people fear
losing in front of others I'm the
complete other way I like losing in
front of others my whole childhood I
would cry the second I would lose in
front of others I like it I think
learning how to lose is the [__]
foundation and I think demonizing losing
to kids eighth place trophies keeping
them away from it fighting with teachers
to get a higher grade yelling at coaches
all that [__] everybody up totally all
right a few more private chats
private jets I would say
pass for 99 who use it to flex and make
people feel worse and try to feel like
somebody
smash for the one percent that their
time is so valuable now that it's
actually thoughtful and strategic to use
a private flight because wasting the
extra three hours commercially is like
Roi negative for them
okay the other Jets the New York ones
I'll smash the living [__] out of that
that is my passion it's my escapism it's
one place where I actually act silly and
not logical I love it healthy for me
it's a balance to my real life it's like
going to church every Sunday for three
hours I love it
all right live beautifully podcast
I'm gonna say now that I've graced the
presence of I'm gonna go with smash
um I I you know even in the way that
you're interviewing me right now I can
sense like the importance of it for you
thank you you know one of the reasons I
continue to do podcasts
is because I know people can leverage me
being a guest to get four guests and
it's like one of the great joys for me
um and so I hope you get some more
guests that you want based on me being
on the show no I just I know you gotta
go thank you so much for absolutely just
saying yes for everything for always
putting yourself out there and um I've
looked up to you for years I met you
years ago at the pop
um Gala and you did a little video for
my birthday with me so it was really
cool and I'm giving this a go and how do
you yeah thank you and I and I hope that
I can even anyone that doesn't know who
you are which I doubt it but if they
don't then by the way that's you know
the selfless part is I know I'm at that
point of my career where I'm it's like
rap it's like I'm giving a feature to
someone and I know that I can put them
on on the flip side to your point if
four people and there's plenty more than
four are listening right now that I've
never heard of me and they hear you know
I'm aware that I say things that are a
little bit different than the masses and
that's really exciting to me and that
comes from great mothering and what my
mom did for me I feel like somebody
heard something I know somebody just
heard something that has never heard of
me and by the way maybe has heard of me
and didn't you know this some people
don't like me because I'm aggressive I'm
competitive I curse but maybe in this
context they're like wait a minute and
so like that's very exciting for me as
well and so thank you for having me on I
curse too because I grew up outside of
Boston in New Hampshire so I'm already
Wicked something awesome
thank you
I think
[Music]